we think about American city like Miami
you think about the color the energy the
deep South American roots
it just becomes a perfect canvas for a
portrait of name our future important
Sydney in the name Neymar jr. I was like
that I've always been a fan of Brazilian
soccer it was just amazing to be able to
connect with Neymar story and just the
excitement around his presence and his
energy and being able to capture that on
the wall one of the challenging things
about paintings is that it's static is
still and her Neymar it was exciting to
figure out how to like bring together
all those elements with the portrait of
his face his various hairstyles always
like showcasing different versions of
who he is so I wanted to focus on that
within the painting but also within the
air and find ways to explore the
textures explore the actions of this
individual as a person and also the
country you represent
[Music]
there's a diamond behind them which
represents the Brazilian flag and in the
Senators at globe and in a way named our
space represents to be an entire country
the image I chose of him is kind of like
this very focused image of him and I
think that's what it takes for him as an
athlete to perform he's got to be able
to focus in the midst of all the
pressure all the expectation hopefully
people in Miami see this painting and it
excites them about just the scale of the
World Cup and these athletes and these
countries are about to put their best
effort out there to win so hopefully
this wall becomes a type of meeting
space for that idea
I'm be Mike and Neymar jr. is larger
than life